asking people to stay at home and
shutting down population movement is
buying time and reducing the pressure on
health systems but on their own these
measures will not extinguish epidemics
[Music]
la decisión Agusta oh gee dear asura
casa el futuro no so del italia en la
nostra mani
[Music]
[Music]
we will be a coronavirus and we will
beat it together and therefore I urge
you at this moment of national emergency
to stay at home protect our NHS and save
lives
this is going to be one of those moments
they're going to write about and they're
going to talk about for generations this
is a moment that is going to change this
nation
[Music]
our future is in our own hands and the
choices and sacrifices we make will
determine the fate of this virus and
really the fate of our victory we will
have a great victory we have no other
choice
[Music]
we have overcome many pandemics and
crisis before we will overcome this one
- the question is how large a price we
will pay
[Music]